in shocking news that capped off a truly
wild week for entertainment in the world
the legendary host of america's favorite
quiz show passed away after a prolonged
battle with stage four pancreatic cancer
the host of the popular quiz show
jeopardy alex trebek died at the age of
80 on sunday november 8th
almost 18 months ago he announced his
dire diagnosis to the world and went on
to beat the odds surviving well beyond
his initial prognosis
according to multiple media outlets
reporting on the sad loss
it seems that trebek spent his final
days with his wife and children
according to a tweet from jeopardy's
official twitter account trebek was
surrounded by the people he loved most
in his last moments
the tweet read jeopardy is saddened to
share that alex trebek passed away
peacefully at home early this morning
surrounded by family and friends
thank you alex despite going through
multiple rounds of treatment trebek
managed to continue working until just
10 days before his death
it has been announced that his final
episode of jeopardy will air on
christmas day
and since his last day of filming was on
october 29th it's clear that he remained
committed to the series right up until
the end
in fact the beloved host told the new
york times in july that although he felt
unwell during his chemotherapy
treatments in the summer
resuming taping for jeopardy actually
made him feel stronger
trebek told the times oddly enough when
we started taping i suddenly started to
regain my strength it's the strangest
thing
it is some kind of an elixir let's go to
work
trebek was candid with fans throughout
his illness and he never shied away from
admitting how unwell the cancer and the
treatments made him feel
in a summer update video shared on
youtube he revealed he was continuing
treatment and that he was feeling good
although he added that the process did
fatigue him a great deal
even though he was dealing with side
effects and a general feeling of
exhaustion
most of trebek's final days were spent
working while much of the world was in
some degree of lockdown due to covet 19
restrictions during the spring
the host made time to finish his memoir
the answer is reflections on my life
it was subsequently published in july
within the pages of his memoir trebek
suggested that he might stop
treatment if the immunotherapy
treatments he was undergoing at the time
stopped working but he later clarified
that the passage was written during a
particularly difficult period of his
illness
trebek said in a statement via the
jeopardy social media accounts
i feel the need to clarify my quote that
if my course of cancer treatment does
not continue to work i would consider
stopping treatment
that quote from the book was written
before my current regimen and i was
going through some bad times
shortly after the publication of his
book trebek returned to the studio where
he began taping season 37 of jeopardy
his final run of episodes was marked by
a number of memorable moments
including recent jeopardy champ bert
thacker tearing up as he thanked alex
for teaching him english
sharing that he would watch the show
with his grandfather every night when he
was growing up
while the late game show host did
mention the idea that he might retire a
few times over the years
it seems fitting that he kept working
almost right up until the end of his
life
but jeopardy was never trebek's first
love that honor goes to his wife jean
and their two children matthew and emily
as well as his adopted daughter nikki
from his first marriage
in his memoir the host turned author
lamented not being able to check
anything major off his bucket list due
to the coronavirus pandemic
however he knew that his life would
never be measured in trips or rewards
and what he wanted more than anything
was to be with his family during his
last days
trebek wrote here i am wanting to enjoy
what might be the last of my days and
what
i'm supposed to just stay at home and
sit in a chair and stare into space
actually that doesn't sound too bad yep
i'll be perfectly content if that's how
my story ends
sitting on a swing with the woman i love
my soulmate and our two wonderful
children nearby
by all accounts it seems that trebek got
his wish